zodiac signs have been around for ages
throughout history many of our ancestors
have looked to the Stars for answers and
guidance and it looks like the apple
doesn't fall too far from the tree
because well here we are we've linked
the signs to some of our favorite Disney
characters so stick around to find out
which Disney characters you have the
most in common with thanks Genie
kind of fonder your kid not that I want
to pick out curtains or anything
Aries March 21st through April 19th if
you were born between March 21st and
April 19th then your zodiac sign is
Aries in animal symbolism the RAM is a
symbol of fearlessness spirit and power
Aries are born leaders who simply do not
take no for an answer they fight for
what they believe in and will put
themselves out there regardless of what
people think of them the energy of an
Aries is most disrupted when they are in
love since they are used to ruling and
leading with their heads and not their
hearts this makes this sign of very
moody partner since they are constantly
in a battle with what they think and
what they feel but also a very honest
one or at least one that is very bad at
telling lies they are most likely to
enjoy the friendship of a Libra and the
love of a fellow Aries if you are in
Aries then you're a lot like Pocahontas
and Simba Taurus April 20th through May
20th if you were born between April 20th
and May 20th then your zodiac sign is
Taurus in Greek mythology the Taurus
constellation was connected to Zeus
himself relating to when he changed
himself into a glorious bowl to help
went over the love of a princess in
animal symbolism the bull is a symbol of
fertility and groundedness torian's are
usually able to see things from a more
realistic point of view and always
finish whatever they've started the
energy of a Taurus is thrown off if
there are any sudden changes in their
routines or if they've been dealing with
insecurity for too long they are easily
discouraged but just as easily
encouraged and loved activities like
cooking and pretty much anything
involving their hands and senses they
are most likely to enjoy the friendship
of a cancer and the love of a Scorpio
the new and Tarzan Tiana and Zeus are a
lot alike
Jim and I May 21st through June 20th if
you are born with
May 21st and June 20th the new zodiac
sign is Gemini this is known as the
tropical sign in Greek mythology the
Gemini twins castor and Pollux were said
to be uniquely placed in the sky by Zeus
himself they were represented by actual
stars that outlined their shapes in the
heavens people born under the Gemini Sun
Sign
tend to go through life forever seeking
a missing half of themselves they really
dislike being alone are always traveling
and can never settle into a routine
since they are always looking for more
feel-good moments and connections a
Gemini will rarely ever be fulfilled by
one way of life so they tend to have
many friends and will always alternate
between two personalities that come very
naturally to them a fun fact is that the
FBI has started releasing studies for
ladies zodiac signs and individuals who
commit crimes and have found that those
least likely to commit a crime are
Gemini's contrary to their mischievious
reputation they will retain their
childish innocence for most of their
lives and will expect it from others in
return Gemini's are very quick to make
sharp turns and leave those who love
them behind if the feeling isn't mutual
since I tend to immediately know when
they found their other half this
fun-loving sign is most likely to enjoy
the friendship of an Aquarius and the
love of a Sagittarius if you are a
Gemini than you are probably Hercules
vanellope or Moana cancer
June 21st through July 22nd if you are
born between June 21st and July 22nd
then your zodiac sign is cancer cancer
is known as the lover and artist but is
also the most dangerous of all the signs
according to real-life statistics it is
associated with the element of water and
the color white cancers tend to be very
artistic loyal and emotional they are
very brave when it comes to protecting
others but not so much themselves since
they tend to avoid any conflict a
cancers energy is most thrown off when
they are away from home for too long
this sign will most likely enjoy their
friendship of a Taurus and the love of
an Aquarius if you are a cancer then you
are probably Milo or Maui leo July 23rd
through August 22nd if you are born
between July 23rd and August 22nd then
your zodiac sign is Leo Leo is the
passionate sign and is associated with
the element of fire they embody passion
Junior
see and creativity the energy of a Leo
is most disrupted when they are ignored
underestimated or not being treated like
the king or queen they know they are
Leos love bringing people together and
giving people life advice they are most
likely to enjoy the friendship of a
Sagittarius and the love of a Capricorn
if you are a Leo then you are probably
Chiara Anna or Shang Virgo August 23rd
through September 22nd if you are born
between August 23rd on September 22nd
the near zodiac sign is Virgo Virgo is
the careful and cautious zodiac sign
they embody the traits loyalty
intelligence hard-working and logical
the energy of a Virgo is most disrupted
when dealing with brood people needing
to ask others for help or being the
center of attention for too long they
enjoy taking care of their pets keeping
everything around them clean and tidy
and cooking up healthy meals this
detail-oriented sign is most likely to
enjoy the company of a Capricorn and the
love of a Pisces if you're a Virgo the
NIR probably Mulan snow white or Prince
Erik Libra September 23rd through
October 22nd if you are born between
September 23rd and October 22nd the new
zodiac sign is Libra Libra is the
balanced and diplomatic zodiac sign
associated with the element of air they
embody the traits of harmony gentleness
incredible wit and grace the energy of a
Libra is most out of balance when
dealing with injustice and ignorance
they keep their circles very small but
really don't like to be alone they will
usually ask for advice but only follow
their own this sign is a breath of fresh
air and enjoys the company of an Aries
but the love of a fellow Libra if your
Libra then you are probably Aurora Belle
Mickey Mouse or Prince Philip Scorpio
October 23rd through November 21st if
you are born between October 23rd and
November 21st then your zodiac sign is
Scorpio Scorpio is the brave an
assertive zodiac sign associated with
the element of water Scorpios are
resourceful brave passionate and loyal
that can also be distrusting jealous and
secretive for a water sign they are by
far the most fierce and fury a Scorpio
is biggest pet peeve is someone who
refuses to try something new or when
somebody can't take a joke this fear
sign enjoys the company of a Pisces and
the love of a Taurus if your score
oh then you are probably jazmine Elsa or
Flynn Rider
Sagittarius November 22nd through
December 21st if you are born between
November 22nd and December 21st the new
zodiac sign is Sagittarius
taja's are generous philosophical and
the most outspoken of all the zodiacs a
Sagittarius feels the need to experience
all things and will wonder the world in
search of the meaning of life they will
do anything to achieve their goals and
retain their childhood innocence for a
very long time just like a Gemini they
have a great sense of humor and possess
the most intense curiosity of all the
signs Sagittarius intial in the lives of
all other signs since they are said to
bring magic itself to the lives of
everyone they encounter don't let them
fool you though because despite their
tough exterior this sign can be very
emotional and hot-headed this unique
sign tends to enjoy the company of Leos
and other stages if it shares the
special bonds with a Gemini if your
Sagittarius then you are probably mogera
Peter Pan or Rafiki Capricorn if you are
born between December 22nd and January
19th the near zodiac sign is Capricorn
Capricorn is the independent sign
associated with the elements of Earth
and the colors brown and black
Capricorn's are responsible disciplined
and masters of self-control they are the
members of your squad making all the
plans and making sure everything goes
smoothly they very much enjoy being
around their families and keeping up
traditions they are also big fans of
music capricoins are quick to learn from
their mistakes but will never admit them
while they are definitely good at
getting what they want through hard work
alone
they can also be know-it-alls and
condescending this is just in their
nature though and they are aware of it
this go-getter sign tends to enjoy the
company of a Virgo and the love of a Leo
if you're a kappa 'then you are probably
a lot like Cinderella Alice or John
Smith Aquarius
January 20th through February 18th if
you are born between January 20th and
February 18th the new zodiac sign is
Aquarius Aquarius is the humanitarian
sign and is associated with the elements
of air and the colors light blue and
silver
Aquarians are very progressive original
and intellectual individuals who enjoy
helping others and fighting for causes
they believe in they enjoy intellectual
conversations
the company of good listeners this sign
can be shy and quiet but very lively and
energetic around the people they are
close to they tend to be the problem
solvers of the group and are very fair
in their judgments one thing an Aquarius
cannot stand is lack of mental
stimulation so they always keep
themselves busy with big group
activities and volunteer work this
visionary sign will likely enjoy the
friendship of a Gemini and the love of a
cancer if you're an Aquarius then you
are probably a lot like King Triton
Esmeralda Jane or Genie wish for
something I'll read you say I want an
isle of the Nile Pisces February 19th
through March 20th if you are born
between February 19th and March 20th the
near zodiac sign is Pisces Pisces is the
gentle and musical sign associated with
the element of water Pisces are
compassionate artistic gentle and wise
they also have a big passion for music
they enjoy watching movies especially
rom-coms and themed parties you can
catch the sign chillin by the pool this
sign can pretty much get along with
anybody and is always willing to help
those around them without expecting
anything in return
Pisces are so empathetic that they can
sometimes be overly trusting a Pisces
dream world is tropical as it is
peaceful with tons of music and romance
this dreamlike sign enjoys the company
of a Scorpio and the love of a Virgo
they however almost always clash with a
Capricorn
due to the signs know-it-all attitude
that we talked about earlier but will
form a deep bond once they get past
their differences if your Pisces then
you are probably a lot like Ariel
Rapunzel or Aladdin and that's all we
have time for in today's in mystical
video if you guys want to see more
zodiac magic be sure to leave a comment
down below give this video a big thumbs
up and of course subscribe to our
Channel this has been a lot of fun so be
sure to come back and check out our next
big topic we'll catch you next time on
two things
[Music]